gleichzeitig würde mich aber echt mal
interessieren wie wie ihr das seht also
ich meine ihr seid ihr die leute die
sich da am ende anschlag service erst
und herz bekommt zu einer neuen folge
monique ruf du und ich bin ja wissen sie
von schild auftakt hallo ich mit einem
dankeschön ok meister da war noch alles
so passiert wie ich er lässt aber seine
gold es liegen
ich habe jetzt gerade kurz vor beginn
dieser aufnahme noch mal mein tisch fast
umgeworfen
weil ich ein bisschen hektik war die tür
zu machen wollte aber das ist ein
anderes thema ich möchte heute mit euch
über was reden und zwar möchte ich mit
euch über den typen reden den ich nicht
hinten kann roger fall da ich möchte mit
euch über eure kommentare reden das ist
mir jetzt eine relativ wichtiges
anliegen und den typ kommt ihm rechtlich
hätten und zwar ich war da vor mir schon
nicht ganz sicher ich gesagt ich
vielleicht bin ich jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich mit euch
ich hatte ein bisschen sorgen und
negative gemischte gefühle
das jetzt nach meinem ausscheiden in war
ja dass man dass man irgendwie relevant
wird ganz ehrlich ich sag's erstmal ganz
ehrlich wie ich gedacht habe dass man
irgendwie irrelevant wird kannst doch
kommt das konfekt der anderen der
stundenlang hinterherläuft so unnötig
die menschen solche menschen braucht die
welt nicht warum vorliegen warum wie
sinnlos er läuft mir hinterher
deswegen ja auf jeden fall habe ich mich
ich hatte halt irgendwie ein bisschen
sorge dass man nie was wahrer
ausschalten das irgendwie die ganze welt
vorbei ist ich weiß nicht was anderen
auszugehen dass man diesmal erlebt haben
und danke schön ja gut dass du jetzt
auch noch da bist du mich dann
wegzuhauen ich glaube ich glaub es hackt
langsam ok kurz von zentrieren
ich weiß nicht ob er das nachvollziehen
könnt also für mich weil es halt schon
bis war halt schon bewegen da
auszuscheiden das war ich traurig danach
war ich so ein bisschen wie soll man
sagen ich habe sie confused gott aber
okay gut aber nicht wegstecken
ich war echt bisschen konfus wusste
nicht was ich machen sollte habe nie
gedacht ich wollte war irgendwie nicht
so
keine ahnung aufgeben so deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht okay machen dieses war
um kommentare aber da hatte ich immer
irgendwie schon so ein bisschen ja
gemischte gefühle wie ich gesagt habe
einerseits hat es mich natürlich gefreut
dass es euch schon mal interessiert
hatten dass ihr das vom formatieren von
der von der aufmachung her gut fanden
das fand ich natürlich eine bestätigung
für mich weil ich ja auch bisschen so
was was eigenes ist also ein kommentar
ist kein news format was was bewusst
keine inhalte zusammenfasst sondern im
kommentiert und darauf aufbauend darauf
selbst ausmacht was eigenes schafft dazu
aber irgendwie ich das bisschen komisch
und es ist eigentlich schade dass ich
jetzt sogar nach denke sie diese diese
idee darauf zu geben als eigentlich gut
war aber ich finde es irgendwie blöd ich
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen leute ich
finde es blöd content über den content
anderer leute zu machen und sich seiner
das interesse der zuschauer quasi nicht
über seine nicht nur über seine eigene
arbeit herzustellen und seine
daseinsberechtigung quasi von anderen zu
beziehen das finde ich einfach nicht
cool muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen was er
denn von rüstung hat mit eleganz glaube
ich ja der hat fünfeinhalb sechs
rüstungs punkte ich habe fünf hat
bisschen mehr müsse man eine combo gm
vielleicht keine probleme ein feuerzeug
ja du marché en gar nix alter schwede
ich erwische ich mit dem aufschlag gar
nix vor dem aufschlag gar nichts ich
werde jetzt mal was ihr über das
nachvollziehen könnt aber ich fand das
gar nicht cool muss ich sagen
die dauer halbes jahr haben nichts zu
essen vor allen dingen scheiße ja das
hat mir irgendwie schon ein bisschen
mitgenommen auch immer wenn ich das dann
aufgenommen hatte sobald zum online war
habe ich mich super gefreut und dann
bleibt ja voll cool die leute feiern und
das hat auch mehr klicks als man andere
content so wenn ich wenn ich jetzt nur
nach klicks gehen würde war ich doch
einfach weitermachen
aber so ist es halt nicht ich hab mich
da dabei halt irgendwie nicht so
wohlgefühlt muss ganz ehrlich sagen so
ich dafür zu nehmen zweiter fall nicht
verziehen wenn ich jetzt irgendwo auch
nur unter verlust drei blöcken und denkt
man gleich mal down euch einfach ein
halbes herz habe ja dass das wollte ich
unbedingt mal ansprechen weil ich nicht
möchte dass ihr denn das baue ich der
eindruck entsteht dass jetzt irgendwie
aus faulheit diese serie quitte nur weil
es mehr arbeitet als meine anderen
videos oder einfach der inkonsequent bin
ich möchte schon genau sagen warum
deswegen mache ich halt das video ja es
ist ein ernsteres video ich hoffe dass
es für euch eine ordnung ja schon seit
so gut schreibt auch meine kommentare ob
ihr das irgendwie nachvollziehen könnt
dass ich das jetzt nicht so super finde
es halt immer irgendwie blöden
beigeschmack wisst ja und ganz ehrlich
ich bin auch immer der erste der sich
über andere lustig macht die dann so was
machen so in der richtung wo man
irgendwie denken könnte dass die jetzt
irgendwie klicks kann oder so da bin ich
der allererste letzte lustig machen sagt
jana durch baku und jetzt war ich selbst
in der position da was zu machen ist
nicht das gleiche aber irgendwie man
kann es auch nicht ganz trennen man
macht halt trotzdem war und warum steht
im titel obwohl man selbst nicht mehr in
bar wo drin ist das hat mich ein
bisschen genervt
deswegen möchte ich die serie jetzt
erstmal pausieren
gleichzeitig würde mich aber echt mal
interessieren
die wie ihr das seht also ich meine ihr
seid ihr die leute die sich da am ende
anschauen oder nicht anschauen oder
kommentieren dislike whatever deswegen
ich weiß nicht wie man kann man das
jetzt irgendwie
griffig zusammenfassen ja hey hey was
hätte sie wahrscheinlich hat er will
schnell einen namen gibt
ich muss ja was ich muss angreifen oder
w-lan greift mich an ok dann versuchen
wir es mal versuchen was machen oder
steffen 24 sekunden los okay es gibt
einfach noch einen anderen ende locker
easy dann machen wir es zeitspiel
bisschen stretching sehr schön was für
escape weißt du wohin fließt das die
leute
ich schwöre es gibt einfach leute die
machen den ganzen tag nichts anderes als
sg zu spielen und erst mal jeden premium
namen durch zu treffen und zu gucken was
für schätzt er hat ob es bei dem sketch
gibt auch steht das hat erst die
erschwert nein anna anna genau ihr markt
erstmal wollen wir nicht stoppt hier
schön ab heute schreiben wir doch bitte
mal in die kommentare
wie er dieses mal kommt r i gefunden
habt wade war es für euch sowas so
irgendwie so klickerei oder wie habt ihr
das wahrgenommen
das will ich bin sicher dass mir das
übel bei meiner entscheidungsfindung
helfen kann wenn ihr euer bild davon
rein schreibt ist es euch wirklich
persönlich wichtig das anzuschauen
lwp thorsten dia schwert wenn ich dir
zeit dass ihr mich zu reden da machst
dich zu regen macht kaputt was man ja eh
keine chance der macht sich dafür nicht
wecken lassen
vor dem vgh den spam der kriege kriege
ich schon wieder ausschlag
ich glaube ich packe erst mal eine
andere auf die 3 man muss ja kurzem ohne
feuerzeug arbeiten also ich glaube da
könnt ihr mir die entscheidung leichter
machen heute wenn ihr das rein schreibt
und ich hoffe auch dass ihr das zu
schätzen wissen so als ich dann einfach
mal ja ich sehe mir noch geholt alter
schwierig ist schon könnte es darum
junge sie
ja ich glaube einfach das macht die
entscheidung für mich leichter ich habe
jetzt einfach mal mein herz auf der
zunge getragen man sagen kann alles
gesagt was mir dazu denke zu dem thema
und jetzt seid ihr dran können gerne
eure meinung dazu in die kommentare
schreiben
minecraft war commentary musters sein
oder nicht wie für uns persönlich ist es
wichtig für euch das zu sehen
oder schaut es an weil über ich mache
oder so haben wir das alles rein alles
was anfällt
wir sind beim nächsten video wie der
haut drei macht's gut und